as a nation we get through around 12
million tons of paper each year
recycling paper and card reduces energy
use and co2 and diverts paper waste from
landfill where it rots and produces
harmful greenhouse gases paper mills
make a variety of papers from different
recycled material to start the recycling
process paper and card is collected
sorted and graded at the paper mill it
is pulped in a tank containing water and
some chemicals which separate the fibres
it is screened to filter out paper clips
labels and other debris and then cleaned
by being spun in a cone shaped container
coloring agents may be added if required
and the pulp mixture which is 99 percent
water and 1% fiber is then pumped on the
paper machine it is sprayed onto a
fast-moving mesh which forms the sheet
and removes much of the water the paper
is then pressed to remove more water
before passing through a series of large
heated rollers until the correct
moisture content and thickness levels
are achieved and is then wound onto huge
rolls the large rolls are then divided
into smaller reels packed and stored
until they are dispatched for further
processing into newspapers cardboard
boxes writing papers or toilet rolls to
find out more about the recycling
process visit recycle now calm